اهلا بكم في الفقره الانسانيه من هنا من
شمال قطاع غزه حيث نسلط الضوء اليوم على
معاناه النازحين في الحصول على الطعام
وعلى الغذاء الاساسي لهم في ظل منع
الاحتلال دخول اي مساعدات او اي مواد
اساسيه للاستمرار في الحياه كما نشاهد هنا
النازحين يعانون من برد الشتاء ويعانون
ايضا من منع الاحتلال من دخول اي مساعدات
او اي مقومات للحياه لا يتوفر اي طعام لا
يتوفر اي شراب ايضا طعام الحيوانات الذي
كان متوفر خلال الايام السابقه الان اصبح
غير متوفر وان توفر اصبح باسعار مرتفعه
جدا في ظل اشتداد هذه الحرب واشتداد
الحصار وما زال الاحتلال حتى اللحظه يمنع
دخول المواد الاساسيه ويمنع دخول الغذاء
مما اضطر المواطنون للبحث عن طعام اخر وعن
سبل اخرى من اجل العيش والاستمرار في
الحياه اضطرينا نعمل خيمه هيك برضه الخيمه
برضه مش رحمنا من القدايه الخيمه كل سقفه
كل هيتها مخز من شضايا شضايا بتنزل على
اودي اطلع منظر اودي بروح على هدات على
مستشفيات ولا حبه دواء ولا حبه برهم نازل
في العيادات فيش ادويه رحت اضطريت اني انا
حتى ادور على اكل لاولادي رحت عليها مناطق
زراعيه امنه يعني انا مواطن لا الليي في
المقاومه ولا الليي في حدا رحت غادا شعير
وتبع حيوانات رحت المه مع شويه خبيزه اللي
هي خضره الغنم الغنم ما باكلها جبتها
لاولادي تم ضرب ن غاده بالقذائف كل يومين
بنظم حالنا ومرات اكثر شيء الاحيان صوموا
الاولاد كيف بنعبي مي رحمه من ربنا بتنزل
مطر بنروح بنحط كل المخيم هنا بحط جراد
الفاضيه بحطها في الساحه يصير نعبي من ميه
ربنا بنعبي هذا غيث من ربنا ورحمه ربنا
بحب غزه ما زالت العائلات تعاني بشكل كبير
في الحصول على هذا الطعام والامر يزداد
ويتفاقم يوما بعد يوم واصبحت مقومات
الحياه غير متوفره نهائيا هنا في شمال غزه
انس الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه